all right we are alive had some
technical difficulties they are all good
people new livestream for you Clyde is
in the house as you can see how you
doing buddy oh there you go really
getting in on this he gets very camera
shy I tried to get him on Fox News the
other day he wouldn't do it but I guess
for a YouTube livestream he's alright
alright buddy how you doing okay so we
are doing our Monday livestream I'm
doing these every Monday and Wednesday
at 8:45 a.m. Pacific 11:45 a.m. Eastern
and this is my way of just getting my
thoughts out to you on a Monday it's
just nice to get a couple thoughts out
to start the week and Wednesday middle
of the week all right you don't have to
chew my head and and I just wanna you
know last week we did two books that are
that are important and relevant right
now I did 12 rules for life by Jordan
Peterson and we did Peter teals
zero to one so we'll do book sometimes
sometimes we'll do what the latest in
the news is we're always gonna do Q&A
with you guys and we're only taking
questions from community members at
Rubin report.com we're not doing YouTube
questions or Twitter questions or
anything like that so you guys can join
us at Rubin report comm and we've got ad
free video and you get full episodes 5
days early and a whole bunch of other
stuff but what I wanted to talk about
today was the sort of ever encroaching
power of the government that we see
happening right now and look I try to
frame everything in a very simple way
the classical liberal lens that I'm
always talking about which is that I
care about individual rights and you
know how to live your life the best way
how you may not do it all the time but
it's up for you to decide how to do it
and the government should protect your
life and it should protect your property
and things should be done at a local
level as much as possible states rights
and then there are limited things that
the federal government supposed to do
like control the borders and immigration
and things like that now we all know
this isn't exactly how the system works
and I think our founding fathers who
wrote some pretty freakin incredible
documents would be would be seriously
depressed and annoyed and angry to put
it lightly at how the government
actually works and also what a giant
money sucking endless albatross of a
system we have sort of hanging
over all of us all the time but in
moments of crisis this is where people
always say to me well Dave what's the
difference between a classical liberal
and a libertarian and most libertarians
when you take that to the to the nth
degree you really want the government
doing virtually nothing yeah protecting
life and property but then you don't
want them stepping in to fix industries
and things like that I don't love those
ideas but I do think in a time of crisis
financial crisis that often the
government causes in the first place in
this case a pandemic medical crisis that
is worldwide that this cannot be excuse
me this cannot be controlled by a state
that the federal government does have to
do something but I would try to leave as
much to the states as possible now
unfortunately I live in the People's
Republic of California over here in Los
Angeles and our government officials are
do in all sorts of stuff so I want to
talk about today are the politicians
going to use this crisis to grab
emergency powers and then once they do
and once they're doing it already by the
way I mean this is happening right now
will they ever give these powers back
unlikely right I mean a politician they
find a crisis never let a good crisis go
to waste so there's a whole bunch of
things happening here right now our
governor Gavin Newsom who was the mayor
of San Francisco and he turned San
Francisco into a literal [ __ ] I mean
there's a there's an app that you can
download that you're recommended to
download actually when you go to San
Francisco to watch to make sure that you
don't step in human poop on the street
it's people that are tracking human poop
from all the homeless people in the drug
addicts and he was the mayor there in
San Francisco and then California said
oh you did such a good job there it's
San Francisco's absolutely disgusting I
don't know when the last time any of you
were there I was there a few months ago
we were doing some fundraising for for
locals which I mentioned to you guys
last week so everything with locals is
actually going really great in Rubin
report calm is the first project of
locals and we've brought on a whole
bunch of great people but we were
fundraising in the midst of when
coronavirus was was exploding and the
stories were breaking and everything
else and it was like we were trying to
like get out of Dodge City because I did
not want to be stuck in San Francisco of
all places anyway our fundraising went
quite well and we're bill
and it's all good but anyway the people
of California said oh you did such a
great job with San Francisco mr. mayor
that we've decided to make you governor
and the only reason Gavin Newsom is
governor is because he has nice hair and
good teeth I mean we all know that it's
not it has nothing to do with his ideas
but Gavin Newsom had a wonderful
wonderful quote I love this that he sees
Koba 19 as a quote opportunity to
reshape the way we do business and how
we govern with more progressive policies
so you really need to understand that
that what many of these people try to do
they see a crisis and then you go oh
crisis time we can almost do anything we
want and that's sort of like when we saw
the stimulus package and there's 25
million to the Art Center the Kennedy
Art Center and all of this pork it's
nothing and we all know it has nothing
to do with helping people right you want
to help people you either make sure that
they can stay in their jobs by helping
companies directly that hire them so you
incentivize companies not to fire people
so that people can keep paying their
bills or you give money directly to the
people now again I know you all know
this my preference would be before all
of that that you would have just been
taking much less money from the people
so they could save more and do with
their money what they want to do in the
first place but I think the ship has
mostly sailed on that one certainly in
this state so all of these guys are
basically jumping in and saying well how
now we have an opportunity people people
seem to want more from the government
how can we sort of stick all of our pet
projects in and there was a an
incredible periscope video by that
Wizard aoc and she was just going on and
on she's making a margarita you probably
saw this a couple days ago she's making
a margarita and she's going on and on
about how the government can never do
too much she's like has the government
ever done too much for you nobody says
that and you really have to think how
reverse to the true liberal position
this is John F Kennedy jr. ask not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country
AOC says the polar opposite of that
and we really need to understand that
that what the progressives and
socialists want right now in many ways
they want the system to collapse because
they've wanted it all along and now they
see a sort of weak underbelly because of
a crisis and as I said earlier you don't
want to let a good crisis go to waste so
here's a couple things that are
happening in this wonderful state of
California we're about to release 3,500
3,500 nonviolent inmates early now in
and of itself non-violent there's
probably a way that it makes sort of
sense but to any of these people have
coronavirus are we testing properly if
regular citizens can't get tests
properly are we really testing properly
in the prisons where we know that these
populations are on top of each other
also right now even if they're
nonviolent criminals often people become
more violent in prison and we know that
we have governors and mayor's saying
that we're not going to arrest you for
petty crimes or turnstile jumping or a
series of other things so would this be
the right time to put more criminals
violent or not on the street that's for
you to decide let's see what else an
extra 37 million in additional funding
for LA homeless housing plus extra money
to buy or lease hotels and motels and la
will get 660 travel trailers to isolate
homeless I mean look this is one of
those things that like most progressive
policies it sort of sounds right like
obviously especially right now we're in
cities that we have a lot of homeless
people you would want to help them even
if you don't want to help homeless
people in general let's say you just
don't think it's the state's job well
you might want to do more right now
because we have a public health
emergency right so if everyone is social
distancing everyone's not going to work
everybody's doing everything that
they're supposed to do but now you have
an uneducated population and people that
are down and out often with mental
health problems and drug problems and
everything else and they're doing all
the wrong things you might want to do
some things to help them but this is one
of those things where it just sounds
good and it's like 37 million oh well of
course of course now of course the next
politician comes in it's a 37
what are you cheap what are you a
right-wing maniac look let's make it 45
but the bigger issue is it's just
throwing money at everything just oh
just it just sounds good we're throwing
money at it let's see but if it works
and we know these things don't work
because why are the places Los Angeles
Sam
Cisco Berkeley why are the places where
we put the most into helping homeless
people why are they the places where
homelessness flourishes the most there's
a million reasons for that and and it
generally does not work here's just a
couple of the things that that the
Democrats tried to jam into the federal
stimulus bill they wanted expanded
Medicare which Bernie's been pushing
forever now you might be somebody who
says I want everyone to have health care
I want everyone to have health care
right now and that you know in a time of
pandemic and again this sort of sounds
right but then you have to think well
can a system support it is them is there
money for it will once the government
takes over will people get proper care
are you telling me that someone who has
a ton of money in private health
insurance has to be on the same plan as
someone that is government subsidized
and this was a debate that the Democrats
were having for a long time could you
even have private insurance and many of
them said no which is absolutely insane
how could they stop you from buying a
policy for yourself they want massive
student let student debt Forgiveness
which we know has been a thing the
entire time which to me is completely
insane I think there's some version
where you could forgive some of it or
you could forgive some level of interest
but when you just forgive all of the
debt well first off you're taking on a
hell of a lot of upper-middle class kids
who went to obscenely expensive schools
30k a year pop so you get let's say 120
grand in debt and then you're gonna bail
them out why should why should the
average taxpayer be bailing out some kid
who went to Syracuse at 35 grand a year
and not only that why would you punish
all the people that actually worked off
all of their student debt right David
David went to Penn State and he had a
ton of student debt and over the years
we paid it back and the last year we
finally made the last payment that's
what you're supposed to do so you
actually start punishing people who play
by the rules but again it sort of sounds
good until you think about it for two
seconds they want to ition free higher
education I don't know what that has to
do with coronavirus if anything we're
learning right now that people that are
in trades that people who have basic
skills that people that are doing things
like instacart and that people who are
programmers and all sorts of other
things who are going to build us a new
Internet to free ourselves from this
nonsense those are
why would we be giving tuition free
college right now how does it's so
strange there's a crisis and their
answer is just the exact same thing that
they were preaching the entire time
let's see diversity inclusion
legislation and you have to have that
because you know unless you really care
about your doctor sexuality or gender
you're a racist bigot don't forget that
one unemployment can now be higher than
your previous pay that's what they
wanted to get in there that's a real
doozy so if you got fired we're actually
going to give you more money than you
were making seems to make sense they
wanted universal trial child care
progressive taxation and affordable
housing so some of these things they all
sort of sound good at some level but
what we really need to be watching out
for is just all of the people who think
they have the easy answers and then in a
time of crisis what we do we all kind of
freak out we're all dealing with you
know going to work all the time suddenly
you're in you're in your house with your
spouse and your kids you're worried
about where you're gonna get food you're
worried about people getting sick you're
worried about your grandparents whatever
it might be and then they can just do
all these things and before you know
what the world is very different than it
was two months ago and I think it's
becoming obvious at this point that no
matter what happens now even if this
thing ends next week at which it's not
going to but even if this thing ends
next week the world is going to be
fundamentally different I think there's
tremendous opportunity here I think all
of us those of us with our heads on
straight and I and I suspect most of the
people watching this I hope you've been
using this time to figure out really
what you want to do what kind of job you
want what kind of relationship you want
to be in do you want to live in a city
or in a rural area do you want to
commute to work can you work from home
just all of these things do you want to
grow food on your land do you want to be
more off the grid I mean there's so many
big questions to be thinking about do
the systems and institutions that we've
all just thought would always exist and
always work will they always exist will
they always work I mean there's great
opportunity here to figure out what kind
of life you want to live unfortunately
these are the mountain conversations
you're gonna hear on CNN or New York
Times or anywhere else okay there oh
here's the most dangerous of all of them
this is this is just beyond imagination
so our mayor here LA
LA's eric garcetti he is starting a
policy where you can actually get paid
to snitch on your neighbors Matt if not
Matt Michael if you're watching this can
you throw up just any of the direct
quotes from Garcetti on that I don't
think I see him right here oh here we go
he has he wants to report violators of
the stay at home order and his quote is
so perfect you know the old expression
about snitches well in this case
snitches get rewards now really think
about that this is a tactic of Soviet
Russia this is a tactic of communist
States this is a tactic of Nazi Germany
neighbors watching out for neighbors now
again you have to be responsible and by
the way I'm seeing responsible people
every day I walk the dog a couple times
and I see responsible people staying
distance from each other I see people
wearing masks all of those things but
now if I was to see two neighbors hug
each other might the mayor of the city
that I live in wants me to snitch on
them and then get a reward for it
think how insane that is there was video
was it in was it in Santa Monica day or
two ago at the beach here in California
somewhere where someone's paddle
boarding and then the cops come get them
it's like I'm all for the social
distancing and we all have to be
responsible and all of that stuff but
when we start turning on each other and
act as government agents against each
other we have seriously seriously lost
the plot and that's what the mayor of
this city that I'm in wants us to do
that is that is deeply deeply dangerous
actually I was literally walking cried
yesterday and I saw two women across the
way and they hugged I saw them hugging I
was like oh that's interesting but me
you know maybe it's a mother and
daughter they live together and that
whatever and then they got in separate
cars so I suspect that they don't live
together unless they were both leaving
to go to different places and then meet
at home and it's like should I have
snitched on them does that solve the
problem here I mean it's really really
dangerous what we're up to over here
okay guys so I want to get to a couple
of your questions at Rubin report calm
as I said we're not taking we're not
doing a live chat on YouTube which is
just a bastion of awful stupidity I am
trying to create something around here
that is a little bit more of a mature
internet internet 3.0 where it's real
people having actual honest decent
conversation and that's what we're
really building with the Rubin Report
community and we've been doing movie
afternoons we did the matrix yesterday
and had a live chat we did happy hour
where we got like a hundred people on
zoom' at once and we all had a drink
together we're doing all sorts of cool
stuff plus you can get ad free video and
you get five day advance release on our
full episodes and all sorts of stuff at
Rubin report.com and that's where I'm
taking the questions from Benjamin asks
do you believe that in that in the next
few weeks that the states might begin to
take matters into their own hands well I
think we're seeing some versions of that
I just gave you a couple bad versions of
it from here in California and more
locally from LA specifically but I would
like to see each state sort of making
more decisions for itself so let's say I
mean I'll give you just like a basic
version of this would be New York is in
a tough bind right now now New Jersey
which shares a border of New York New
Jersey is actually in a bit of a tough
spot too but let's say the real hotspots
of this thing which seemed to be Queens
New York City I mean these places where
they're densely populated it's very hard
to do social distance and you share
elevators with people I mean think about
the people that are in these giant
high-rises in any city you know 30 40
storey buildings where there's you know
four elevators to get thousands of
people up and down all the time it's
almost impossible to social distance and
not only social distance but then you're
touching elevators and doorknobs and
hallways and a series of other things so
the city's the big cities right now
really have some stuff that they have to
work out in New York City is
particularly in a precarious position
because they have their socialist
lunatic Mayor Bill DeBlasio who is
telling people to go out just a few
weeks ago right and get down to
Chinatown and a whole bunch other stuff
I mean these people are these people are
not wise now I would be all for the
governor is saying we're dealing with it
a certain way in our city our state and
our cities however that is and the
governor is taking as much control now
it's not perfect and this is why we do
need a federal government because
obviously a virus the
doesn't mind doesn't see a border and go
oh I'm not gonna jump over that border
but if each state decides what their
policies are I think that's how you get
the experiment that our founders wanted
right the American experiment of all of
these different states figuring out
what's best for them and then how they
can work together and then occasionally
we have to figure out what the federal
government can do so I do think we'll
see more of that and it seems like right
now by the way that even though New York
is struggling quite a bit that Cuomo
right Andrew Cuomo who's the governor of
New York he seems to be becoming one of
the stars here now it's a little unclear
if anything he's doing is working but I
think he is giving people a sense of
reassure man he does seem like a
professional he seems like a competent
executive again I don't know about the
specifics of everything that's happening
there but I could honestly see at this
point I mean Biden it's just it's just
ridiculous I don't want to get into all
that right now but it's like you know
the Democrats might just be like all
right Joe just get out of the way or Joe
will just say I can't do it or Joe will
pick somebody as his VP although he said
he had to pick a woman as a VP of good
you know this is the same guy who also
said if you're going to jail it's not
what your birth gender is it's whatever
gender you identify as as to which jail
you're going to go to so maybe he could
pick Andrew Cuomo the whole thing is so
stupid but it seems to me that the
Democrats are in a really tough spot
right now because the Biden thing is
just an abject disaster these videos
that he's putting out or depressing and
and and confusing and crossed up and
nutty and I got I got it and there you
go all right so we'll see what happens
with with Cuomo but I would like to see
more state control as a general level
James asks as a classical liberal do you
think there are any circumstances where
the government can suspend
constitutional rights right now some
states are violating the First Amendment
freedom of religion and assembly and the
second amendment banning gun purchases
so the gun purchases one just very
clearly I am completely against we are
in a time right now that we're watching
an unprecedented moment happen and
people absolutely with
out question have the right to protect
themselves you have the right to protect
yourself you have the right to protect
your family your property and everything
else so these states and cities that are
banning gun sales that absolutely I see
almost no legal way around it I'm not a
lawyer but I don't see a real legal way
around how this is a not a violation of
the Second Amendment as far as the First
Amendment and freedom of assembly there
is this is this is the push and pull
between between freedom and public
safety right I mean this is where
they've had a couple edicts put out
there and who was it it was de Blasio I
think it was de Blasio of course it was
the Blasio who said that he said temples
and churches that let people get
together could be permanently closed now
look we should be advising all of these
communities to follow the six-foot
social distancing order and the rest of
it and not doing big congregations and
figuring out ways to do things digitally
and all that but first off I don't know
what order he thinks he can put out
there that would permanently close a
congregation a temple a church a mosque
or anything else I don't know that that
exists permanent closure what if they
did went ahead and did it and then they
got fined and then they fired the whole
leadership team there you're gonna still
permanently close them I mean it's just
it's just dangerous language that you're
using it's sloppy and dangerous language
but the freedom assembly point is
interesting we do have freedom of
assembly so in some way right now
is the First Amendment under attack if
we can't assemble well I think there is
some legitimacy to that and this again
is where we have to all I would want as
much of this to be on us and if let's
say if it was found out that a temple or
a church or a mosque or a community
center or whatever was was doing secret
underground meetings of 20 people my
preference would be that you break it up
and you know maybe for a week you don't
let them congregate there now we know
that they're gonna congregate somewhere
else if they really want to you can't
legislate human behavior away right I
mean this is what I always say about the
the big government socialists and
progresses they want to build a perfect
system where we'll all behave perfectly
except we are not perfect and we're the
ones building the system and that's why
they always end up killing a lot of
people
right that's why the the thumbnail for
this video we thought that us was the
right guy because he wanted to
accumulate a lot of power and then what
do you have to do you have to take out a
lot of people to build your perfect
utopia so in many ways they're acting
like Thanos okay I'll get to one more
question real quick we're trying to keep
these two 20 minutes because I know you
guys are overloaded and it's like we're
not trying to belabor everybody and I
want you guys to find a multitude of
places to get information and feel sane
and the rest of it real quick do you
think it's possible this is from Kent do
you think it's possible for this
situation to become militarized I pray
not I think from what I've seen over the
last couple days there is some hopeful
stuff out there there are some you know
it's a little hard to trust which models
you're paying attention to and and all
of that stuff but it does seem like from
what I'm seeing that over the next two
weeks we may actually see the peak of
this thing and then slowly the numbers
will go down it seems like perhaps Italy
is seeing a little bit of that right now
and it's really hard to figure out who
to trust
so could it become militarized I pray
not I don't want soldiers on our streets
but this goes back to why I wouldn't
want neighbors niching on neighbor once
you start doing that then you're saying
okay well now the police should show up
to people's house and then once it gets
bigger than that well then it's like
alright now the military she show up to
people's houses and should people be
allowed to tweet what they want in their
houses if it's misinformation I mean you
know this information I use that I use
quotes around that because often
misinformation is just the stuff you
find out it's true a couple months later
anyway a lot of things to think about
join us at Rubin report com where you
can submit questions and the rest of it
it's Monday have a good week everybody
try to get it I would say this I don't
mean this to be a criminally negligent
but if you can take a walk sit in the
backyard you know just a couple little
tips for you guys because you know I
work from home this is my home so
although we're in an odd situation like
everybody else my my director matt is
now directing from his home and we've
got David running all our equipment here
and I don't have any of our crew or
anything else here we
you normally work from home in my home
is not only my studio but my office but
like a couple little things like have a
glass of water when you wake up before
you do anything else just a couple
glasses like a couple gulps just kind of
stand there let your body reset for a
second I think another really nice thing
to do is find some morning music I like
sort of like some light jazz I like some
ambient stuff there's this band shores
and funk that I found on Spotify that I
love I think having a little something
playing in the background I like a lot
of stuff without words in the morning
just to kind of like let the brain go
make sure yeah get some fresh air like
it's gonna be raining in LA the next
couple days but get some fresh air when
you can try to walk your dog you know
take if you got to stand up and get
outside all that stuff like do a couple
other things to figure out how to make
this a little bit easier that's what
we're all trying to do say hi to a
neighbor from 6 or more feet and the
rest of it okay guys have a great day
everybody stay sane and we'll keep on
keepin on